if you are watching this video your
healthcare provider has asked you or
someone you know to get a blood test to
measure your cholesterol levels the
National Institutes of Health
cholesterol treatment guidelines
recommend you have a blood test every
five years if you are 20 years or older
the test called a fasting lipoprotein
profile measures your levels of total
cholesterol
LDL also known as bad cholesterol
HDL also known as good cholesterol
and a type of fat in your blood called
triglycerides
during this test a blood sample will be
taken after you have not eaten for nine
to twelve hours fasting is important to
ensure accurate results for this test
the total cholesterol goal should be
less than 200 milligrams per deciliter
for most people an ideal HDL or good
cholesterol should be 60 or higher an
ideal LDL or bad cholesterol should be
less than 100 and fasting triglycerides
should be less than 150
if you have high blood cholesterol
levels you have a greater risk of heart
disease
in heart disease blood vessels called
coronary arteries become narrowed or
blocked by a waxy substance containing
cholesterol called plaque
I'm plaque may reduce or block the flow
of oxygen-rich blood to your heart
muscle and cause a heart attack
there are many known risk factors for
heart disease risk factors you can
control include high blood cholesterol
and triglycerides
high blood pressure
diabetes pre-diabetes
overweight or obese
smoking
lack of physical activity
unhealthy diet
and stress
risk factors you can't control include
age
gender
and having a family history of heart
disease
if you already have heart disease and
multiple or severe risk factors
your doctor may lower your LDL goal to
less than 70
your specific goals may vary depending
on your health situation ask your doctor
what your lipid goals should be